the smoke is cleared but the Damage Done
in termosiah is indelible and attacked
by Israeli settlers on Wednesday left
cars and houses burned 12 Palestinians
injured and one dead villagers say Omar
katin was shot by Israeli forces who
arrived after the settlers had retreated
he walked into the fire to rescue others
he didn't care about himself
he cared about the safety of others
I'm so proud of him I'm so proud of him
we're all so proud of him
EU officials and other diplomats arrived
on Friday to evaluate and to condemn
according to the accounts we have
received from numerous sources indeed a
group of settlers many many settlers
came here
I would call them terrorist settlers
because they spread Terror in the
vicinity and in the neighborhood here
by shooting with live rounds and fire at
Palestinians
the attack was part of a wave of settler
violence that came after four Israeli
settlers were shot dead by Palestinian
attackers at a petrol station on Tuesday
that followed a large-scale Israeli raid
on Janine on Monday that left seven
Palestinians including two children dead
and scores wounded the U.N on Friday
demanded Israel reset its actions to
minimize the use of lethal force and
protect people's right to life this
week's violence in the occupied West
Bank risks spiraling out of control
fueled by strident political rhetoric
and an escalation in the use of advanced
military weaponry by Israel there was
more strident rhetoric though from
Israel's security minister visiting a
settlement Outpost deemed illegal under
Israeli law one the government plans to
endorse retrospectively
we must settle the entire land of Israel
and in parallel to settle the land we
must carry out a military operation to
topple buildings to kill terrorists not
one or two but dozens and hundreds and
if needed 1000 there has been pressure
on the Israeli government from other
quarters as well Morocco has delayed
again hosting an arab-israeli U.S Summit
the U.S ambassador has said Washington
won't stand by and allow settler
violence to continue the Israeli
military has condemned it as well but
there's pressure in the other direction
from within the government from
far-right settler leaders who now hold
positions of unprecedented power Harry
Fawcett Al Jazeera Ramallah in the
occupied West Bank